what is up everybody it's 414 anime here
for anime or Pro and today I will be
breaking down and explaining every
sheikai from bleach we certainly have a
lot of shikai to look into today so
strap in for today's epic one where we
will break down the soul Reaper zompoc
toe their shikai's release call and its
powers we've also covered every Bank
iron bleach too so make sure to check
that video out after this one link to
that is in the video description now if
you do enjoy these bleach videos on the
channel and you'd like to see more you
know what to do smash that like button
if you haven't already make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications you can also follow us on
Twitter and Instagram at anime Opera and
now without further Ado let's jump into
It spoilers and all
shikai means initial release and it is
the second form of a zombac toe from its
sealed state in order for a soul Reaper
to achieve shikai the Shinigami must
learn the name of their zompoc toe in
order to do this they must communicate
with the spirit of their zompoc toe in
their world and form a bond with it once
they have achieved this and attained
their shikai the first ever release of
it is known as manifestation to achieve
their shikai the soul Reaper must chant
their zompoc toes release call also
known as kygo these chants are unique
and individual to each zompoc toe and
can range from a simple word to more of
a sentence or poem this is all dependent
on the zompokto's spirit in terms of its
personality or nature if you will upon
its release the zompoc toes blade will
change in shape and its abilities become
available to their shiny garming to
achieve shikai is a mark of progression
within the Shinigami ranks as it is
proof not only of their power but also
their control of their zompoc toe to
achieve shikai is a requirement for a
Shinigami to rise through the ranks
especially if they are looking into
becoming a seated officer or a
lieutenant as this is one of the first
things that a captain will look for when
choosing their membership
so let's start looking into every
sheikai with series protagonist and
substitute Soul Reaper Ichigo Kurosaki
after this we will then move through the
soul society's ranks
ichigo's sampocto is called zangetsu
which is translated to mean slaying Moon
Ichigo zampokto is certainly a topic due
to the fact that he found out that he
doesn't possess what we would consider a
normal zompoc toe but one that is a
fusion of both his Shinigami and Hollow
Powers this he didn't find out until
chapter
547 so we will focus on his shikai here
his shikai comes in the form of two
separate black swords one is the size of
his previous sword that we are all very
familiar with and the second blade is
like that of a knife the larger blade
represents his inner Hollow that has
been known as a you know variety of
different names including Hollow Ichigo
why Ichigo and the hollow within Ichigo
this is his Shinigami and Hollow Powers
the Shinigami powers that he had
inherented from his father and the
hollow powers that he had inherited from
his mother the smaller blade represents
the old man the old man is the awesome
looking figure that Ichigo acknowledges
as zongetsu and is the manifestated
spirit of ichigo's Quincy Powers now
ichigo's shikai powers are both energy
attacks and for me one of the most
iconic anime attacks ever the first is
of course getsuga 10 show which is
translated as meaning Moon Fang Heaven
piercer with the slash of his zompoc
toes zangetsu absorbs some of ichigo's
spirit energy and then releases it as an
energy blast in the shape of a crescent
moon that packs destructive power
immense force and Deals a huge amount of
damage Ichigo can fire against Suga
tencho blast with both of his swords
with the smaller blade he simply points
it towards his Target and makes a small
slashing motion the bigger sword is the
more powerful of the two and when used
with this Blade the color of the gets
Suga tension attack is completely black
to tie in with this each go also has
getsuga jujisho which is translated as
meaning Moon Fang cross-shaped piercer
here he will fire and getsuga tensho
with each of his blades at the same time
in a crossed motion this fuses the two
gatsuga tensho blasts into one insane
attack
o is the captain of the first Division
and the head captain he was formerly
captain of the eighth division his
zompoc toe is called carton kyokatsu
which is translated to mean flower
Heaven bone of Madness its sheikhai
command is when the flower wind rages
the flower God Roars when the wind of
Heaven rages the god of the underworld
snares in its shikai form cartoon
kyokatsu becomes a pair of giant black
curved Chinese swords the wakizashi
sword is used for Speed while the Tachi
is used for power strikes so the power
of carton kyokatsu shikai is to make
children's games reality the zompoc toe
makes and sets the rules of these games
and those who step within its spiritual
pressure are forced to play and obey by
these rules which also includes shunsui
himself these games are essentially you
win you live and if you lose
you die so let's look into the games
that we know of lazy spinning top is a
technique that represents the spinning
top game where large wind blasts are
fired towards his opponent coming
together to form a tornado Mountain
demon was seen in shoonsui's battle
against Stark shunsui explained that the
winner of this game was whoever was
higher than the other wins Shadow Demon
was a game where whoever gets their
Shadows stepped on loses however this
game allowed its players to manipulate
their own Shadows making it harder for
their opponent to step on them lustrous
demon was a color-based game in which
you say what color you want to cut with
your sword and it won't be able to cut
anything else that isn't that said color
now if the color that you call out is a
color that doesn't appear on your own
body the damage will be minimal even if
that attack would have been a fatal one
prior to this game but it works in both
ways that if that color does exist on
your own body then the damaged Dell is
equivalent to how much of that color you
have on your own body so to deal out
maximum strength it would be
advantageous to call out your skin color
or the color of your clothing if you
were wearing black robes as an example
basically the gist of this game is risk
in order to deal greater damage to your
enemy you must also increase the risk to
your life as well the next game we saw
was the Dharma doll fell down this is
based on the children's game Red Light
Green Light where either shunsui or his
opponent are marked as being it the
other can then travel towards the one
who is it on a trail of their spiritual
energy however they have to catch them
by surprise because if the one who is it
sees their opponent while they are
moving the opponent loses the game the
final game is Shadow sending which is
based on the children's game chichar no
kago Curry where children would stare at
their shadow on the ground for a few
seconds before looking at another
service which will produce an after
image of their Shadow how the game plays
out is that shunsui or his opponent can
project an after image after staring
hard at their Shadow and then project an
after image in a different location the
higher the opponent's spiritual energy
the more realistic the after image will
appear to be
Yamamoto was the former captain of the
first Division and head captain of the
13 court guard squads his zompoc 2 is
riojin jaka which is translated to mean
flowing blade young flame rijin jaka is
the oldest and most powerful fire type
zampark toe its strength is so
overwhelming that it has greater
attacking power than all of the other
zampokto in the soul Society now it
shikai command is probably my most
favorite of all the shikai commands out
there as you you as you definitely know
if you've seen some of our previous
bleach videos but it is all things in
the universe turn to ashes just sounds
incredible now in it sheikai form the
blade is completely engulfed in fire the
weapons Aura simply incinerates
everything that it is swung at leaving
nothing behind but Ash the heat that
comes from the Flames of ryajin jaka in
its shikai form are hot enough scorched
the sky itself now ryoshi and jaka has
some pretty amazing abilities when it's
in its shikai form which include
Fortress blaze a huge wall of flame is
erected surrounding its Target before
becoming a sphere which traps the Enemy
Within
torch is a technique where Yamamoto can
create a giant Inferno with a simple
wave of his zompoc toe the Flames from
this Inferno engulf and consume its
Target until only Ash remains these
Flames can also be controlled by
Yamamoto himself to only attack the
targets that he himself chooses not only
that but he can also control how intense
these Flames are as well flames of hell
is the last technique but equally as
insane as the others where seven or more
pillars of flame are created these
pillars are to trap his opponent within
their Inferno and Destroy them
completely the power of this ability is
so intense that anyone trapped within
its boundary including Yamamoto himself
will be incinerated
was the former Lieutenant of the first
division Under head Captain Henry USA
Yamamoto where he held this post for
about 110 years children was called
gonrio Maru which is translated as
solemn Spirit the release command for
his shikai is Pierce and his sampocto's
appearance turns into that of a Rapier
sword which looks very elegant
especially for a man such as chojiro now
unfortunately that is all we know about
his shikai which is a shame as we know
just how awesome his Bankai is going off
the knowledge of what his bonkai is I
presume his shikai must also be a
lightning type but that's just my take
soy Fern is the captain of the second
division as well as the
commander-in-chief of the Stealth Force
her zonpokto is Susa mabachi translated
as meaning hornet she enters
zuzumabachi's shikai release by using
the command sting all enemies to death
the sword shrinks in size and takes on
the form of a black and gold Gauntlet on
her right hand it has a small chain and
a blade that looks like a hornet sting a
needle on her middle finger the needle
is around two of soy phone's fingers in
length and though the blade has become a
smaller needle it still has enough
behind it to block the incoming attacks
from her opponents now Hershey Kai's
special ability is called double strike
finisher and it has two steps to it the
first is to stab her enemy with the
needle which leaves a butterfly shaped
Mark where she struck her opponent this
Mark is called The Bee Crest flower and
is now the target area for the second
step or I guess you could say attack for
this ability now if soy phone can strike
her opponent a second time in that exact
same spot it will ultimately result in
that person's death and is known as
death in two steps a much larger bee
Crest flower appears in its place which
will destroy her Target's body so the
ability is actually that of a Venom that
spreads throughout the target's body in
mere minutes however the more spiritual
pressure that her target has the longer
the Venom will take to spread now these
crests are maintained by soy phones well
and are impossible to remove unless soy
phone so chooses soy phone has said that
she could only maintain these crests for
about half an hour which was always more
than enough time for her to land that
second and most fatal strike
Mauricio omeda is the lieutenant of the
second division under his captain soy
phone and is also the patrol corpse
corpse Commander his zombokto is called
gigetsu Buri which is translated to mean
five heads omaida's shikai command is
crush or smashem in the viz translation
where his zompoc toe turns into a huge
spiked ball and chain the chain is
attached to the hilt of his zompoc toe
and can be used as a ranged base weapon
now the very underwhelming thing about
his shikai which let's face it suits its
master in this case am I right anyway is
is that it doesn't have any special
abilities itself amida will only use it
to throw at his enemies or to use as a
shield to block incoming attacks so we
can really only speculate that omeda
hasn't really mastered his shikai all
that well especially when you take into
mind the amount of times that it has
been cracked or completely destroyed by
other opponents
Rogero otorobashi more commonly referred
to as simply Rose is the captain of the
third division and was previously a
captain 100 years prior to his Exile his
zompoc toe is called kinshara which is
translated to mean golden Charla he has
an ability called arpeggio where he
levitates his zompoc toe sheathed within
it Scabbard in front of him horizontally
he then begins to move his fingers over
the zampokto as if he was playing the
piano which is also accompanied by the
sound of sad notes being played when
Rose does this his hands glow a golden
color as a wire appears that wraps
around his Target the notes that he
plays will then constrict the wire
crushing the target trapped within now
to release his zompoc toe into its
shikai form his command is simply play
which is fitting for the whole piano
thing we were just talking about his
zonpok Cho takes on the form of a long
golden whip with a flower at its tip
that will pale his Target this whip is
similar to that of renger shikai where
it can extend and retract making it an
obvious ranged weapon also while in use
the whip makes the light sound of a
piano playing so it has an ability
called Golden cell tree Sonata number 11
16 day old Moon Rose long name right so
the flower at the top of the whip will
attach itself to his opponent Rose Taps
the Whip and instead of a piano playing
it is now the sound of guitar strings
the sound vibrations travel through the
Whip and create a Vortex of sound that
will create a blast when it reaches the
flower that is attached to his Target at
the end big boom basically
Keen ichimaru was the former captain of
the third division until he betrayed the
sole Society along with both sosuke
Eisen and kaname tozen his zampokto is
called Shinto which means sacred spear
when translated his shikai is activated
using the command shoot to kill his
shikai is activated using the command
shoot to kill and its special ability is
that it extends at very high speeds
impaling his enemy with a ferocious
Force as well as that he will swing his
zompoc toe around while it is extended
to destroy wide areas or take out
multiple targets at once his sheikhai
can extend to up to 100 times its
original length which earned it the
title of Hundred Swords
next up is shusuke armor guy who was
from an anime only Arc amagai was
another former captain of the third
division succeeding
ichimaru his zampokto is called Riker
which means lightning flash his shikai's
release command was sever now the
appearance of his zompoc toe changes to
a Long White Blade with a hook at the
end and shell-like pipes at its Hilt
these pipes emit powerful Flames that
produced the sound of a trumpet and its
special ability all revolve around the
pipes that emit this fire armor guy can
heat up the blade which causes it to
become a much more intense fire color
armor guy can then shoot Fireballs from
the hook of his zompoc toe launching
them forward with the swing of his sword
he can also slam his zompoc toe into the
ground with a fireball concentrated at
the tip to send Flames straight towards
his Target
izuru Kira is the lieutenant of the
third division under Captain Rogero
otarabashi and formerly of guinichimaru
and of course shusuke armor guy izuru
zambocto is called wabisque which is the
penitent one when translated it's shikai
release command is raise your head to
which the blade of his zomp October
comes straight and its tip bends in two
90 degree angles a very simple look to
this one but for some reason this one
always stood out to me like as a really
cool and unique look and talking of cool
and unique its special ability also fits
that bill for me what would be skate
does is that it doubles the weight of
any object that it strikes be them a
living or non-living object and the
awesome thing about wobisuke's effect is
that it can continually multiply the
weight of what it strikes meaning it
isn't a one-time thing he can strike an
opponent's sword making it twice as
heavy and then strike it again to double
that meaning that the sword is now four
times as heavy and another strike would
double that again for eight times its
normal weight and so on it's just it's
just amazing the crazy thing about this
ability is that it seems to be Limitless
and would be gay can multiply the weight
of what it strikes as many times as it
wants and with just a few strikes of an
opponent's sword izuru's enemy will
seemingly become immobile and I guess if
not just strike it again right I always
tend to think of its ability as a smash
until it works kind of job
now when his opponent is on their knees
before him the gruesome form of his
sheikhai's design comes into play as he
will hold what Beast Gay's curved blade
beneath their neck and lift it like that
of a reverse guillotine
Riku tokakushi is the third seed of the
third division under Captain Rogero
otorobashi his zompoc toe is called
shunjin which is translated as meaning
spring dust his shikai's release command
is coil upward and his zompoc toe takes
on the form of a scythe now the
interesting thing about riku's Scythe is
that the cutting part of the blade is on
the outside of the curve rather than the
inside that you would consider as a
normal for a scythe unfortunately we do
not know of his shikai's ability but its
appearance is certainly most impressive
takasuna gory is the fifth seat of the
third division under Captain Rogero
otorobashi his zompoc toe is called
magaribu which is translated as meaning
whistling Winter Wind his shikai's
release command is sound with a blow now
his appearance changes to look like that
of a large Cleaver that has more of an
angled and wider Blade the blade itself
also has a few holes running across the
length of that blade again another
seated member of the third division
whose sheikhai ability isn't known but
again I I guess props for it shikai's
design it does look pretty cool
Asuka katakura is the sixth seat of the
third division under Captain Rogero
oturabashi his zambokto is called
katakage which is translated as meaning
summer shade his shikai's release
command is drown out and his zompokto's
appearance changes to where the blade
splits into two liked prongs and you
know what's coming here but yes yes
another shikai we don't know the ability
of here third division needs to up his
game that's for sure
final third division member is an anime
only one but a pretty impressive one
nonetheless Makoto kibune was the former
third seat of the third division under
Captain shusuke armor guy his zonpokto
was called repu which means Gale when it
is translated his shikai's release
command was rage violently I don't know
why but I'm a fan of that release
command probably the violent nature of
it his zompoc toe changes in appearance
to this very large and very awesome
three-bladed weapon that are connected
by a large Pole now two of the three
blades are like that of Arrow points at
either side of said pole and the third
is a curved one in between them very
awesome looking sheikai here and one
that has certainly packed a punch we do
not know of his shikai's special
abilities but to finish off the third
division in standard fashion
cool looking sword bro
s
the former captain of the fourth
division she was actually one of the
oldest captains among the Seoul society
and was their best healer no doubt she
was also the first person to hold the
name of kempachi so her zonpokto was
called minazuki and her Bankai was of
the same name though their translations
are different so in terms of a zompoc
toe when translated that meant flesh
drops Gorge pretty tasty right so the
release for her shikai is unknown but in
its released form minazuki takes on the
form of a green giant one-eyed creature
that looks like a manta ray this
creature is used for transportation
where it can either fly or grow legs for
transportation on land hashikai's
special ability is healing those that
are placed within the creature's mouth
the person placed inside will be
swallowed and stored within the
creature's stomach where the acid will
cover that wounded individual now the
creature's stomach acids are like that
of a strong medicine or ointment the
creature itself can carry up to six
people in its stomach at one time and
once the healing process is completed or
at unohana's command the creature will
regurgitate the people out of its mouth
pretty
pretty tasty
as Sonic kotetsu is the current captain
of the fourth Division and former
Lieutenant under Captain retsu unohana
her zonpokto is called itegumo which is
translated as meaning frozen snow her
shikai's release command is simply run
and when it is activated her zompoc toe
has two extra blades come out of the
hilt at 45 degree angles alongside of
course the main blade now for a Sony I
feel it's a real shame that we do not
know about her shikai or bonkai's
abilities for that matter you know with
her being a captain and all as well as
the fact I personally think she is a
pretty awesome character you know it's a
shame that we don't know anything about
it but maybe one day we'll find out a
bit more about what she is exactly
capable of
[Music]
Yamada is the third sea of the fourth
division on the captain asane katetsu
his zompoc toe is called hiso gomaru
which means gourd when translated his
zompokto is pretty cool in the way that
it doesn't deal damage when it strikes a
person but instead it actually heals
them yes this isn't all helpful in a
fight but as a support this is a very
useful zampark toe to have on your team
so his shikai's release command is
fulfill when hinatra heals a person's
wound with his zompoc toe a red smoke
appears that begins to fill up a gauge
on it the more severe the wound the more
of this red smoke that will appear and
fill up the gauge now when this gauge is
full his shikai transforms into shuiro
hisa gomaru translated as Vermilion
colored gourd and it takes on the form
of a scalpel its special ability is its
form of offense where it will
concentrate every wound that is he
healed into a huge attack that looks
like that of Acero this is activated
when hanataro performs a slashing motion
with his zompoc toe after this attack is
unleashed the healing properties of his
sonbokto are lifted meaning he can use
his zompoc toe on the offensive however
given the fact that his zomboto is in a
scalpel form it really isn't that
effective for combat unless it's like
sneak attacks and stuff maybe belena
one-on-one had just he'd get wrecked man
he'd get wrecked
Shinji hiroko is the captain of the
fifth division he was also a captain 100
years prior to his Exile Shinji was of
course the leader and recruiter of the
visors as well so his zonpokto is called
sakur nade which means counter-stroke
when translated his shikai release
command is collapse and when in this
form his zomp octo becomes a very large
ring that allows Shinji to rotate
sakanade around his hand without
grabbing the zompoc toe at all the
spinning is the shikai special ability
so the ability is called upside down
world and as the zompoc toe is spun a
pink mist is created this Mist has a
very pleasant Aroma to it but if smell
the target will fall into an optical
illusion this illusion affects his
opponent's eyesight and sense of
direction even the injuries that they
sustained aren't in the location that
they think they are everything is thrown
off and it will cause all all sorts of
effects including nausea vertigo and
confusion and no matter how strong the
opponent they will all fall victim to
soccer nowaday's Illusions all are
unable to adapt to them
sosuke Eisen is the former captain of
the fifth division before he betrayed
the sole Society along with his
followers geen and tozem his zompoc toe
is called Kyoko suigetsu which is
translated to mean mirror flower water
Moon his shikai release command is
shatter which will activate and
deactivate it so the special ability of
Kyoko suigetsu is complete hypnosis it
will control all five senses of his
Target that they misconceive a person's
form feel and smell to be that of their
enemies now to fall under its hypnosis
the target must initially see kyoka
soygetsu upon its release and by seeing
it just once they will fall under its
control every time that it is released
even if they haven't seen it in a very
very long time the power of kyokosoi
getsu's hypnosis is so strong that even
if a person knows they are under its
control they will still fall victim to
its effects this ability is just truly
devastating and one that really matches
eyes and so well it's incredibly useful
to him both in and out of combat not
only can he make his Target think that
other people are their enemies but he
can use it so it affects their view on
himself to create decoys so he can hide
his true movements and strike at the
right opportunity
is the lieutenant of the fifth division
on the captain Shinji hirako and
formerly of sosuke Eisen her zompoc toe
is called Toby ume which is translated
as meaning flying Plum Tree her shikai's
release command is snap and her zompoc
toe undergoes a pretty rad
transformation so it transforms and
becomes double-edged and it has multiple
prongs that stick out of it now
hershikai used to only have two prongs
that came out of the blade but after
eisen's defeat her shikai grew a third
and the special ability of her shikai is
that it releases powerful explosive
Fireballs that Momo can fire from her
zompoc toe the blade releases a
high-pitched cry when these Fireballs
are shot from her zampark toe
is the captain of the sixth Division and
the 28th head of the kuchiki clan who
are one of the four Great Noble Clans
within the sole Society his zompoc toe
is called zenbon zakura which means
thousand cherry blossoms when translated
his shikai release command is scatter
now the special ability of his shikai is
that his zenbon zakura separates into a
thousand tiny fragments that are
incredibly sharp and look like cherry
blossom petals the tiny blades disperse
from the hilt of his zompoc toe and when
Bianca swings his Hilt the tiny blade
shred his opponent at his control biokya
can also use them as a form of Defense
as they are strong enough to block
incoming attacks from his enemy
interestingly zembonzakra also has a
safe Zone that protects bjokia from his
own attacks where they will not cut
anything within an 85 centimeter range
of biochia himself however if he so
Wishes the blades can enter that safe
Zone
renji abarai is the lieutenant of the
sixth division under his captain byakia
kuchki he also previously served as the
sixth seat of the 11th division under
kenpachi's Rocky his zombokto is called
Sabi Maru which means snake tail when
translated his shikai release command is
raw and his zompoc toe transforms into
one of the best and most unique looking
in the entire series of course my
opinion again there but it's rad man so
his zombok toe transforms into a blade
made out of segments that get wider as
they go up the blade each of these
segments have a spiked protrusion coming
from them that again are longer the
further they go up the blade so these
segments can then multiply a number
seemingly without limit when renji
thrusts the blade each of these segments
are connected by a stretchable thread
renji will of course use his shikai more
like that of a whip and because of the
protrusions it can deal some really
nasty damage as we saw when he cut
ichigo's shoulder in the early part of
the series renji can however use his
sheikai like that of a normal sword if
he so wishes now the interesting thing
to note about zabimaru is that it is
supposedly the hardest shikai to master
among the lieutenants though it was
renji himself who stated this so there
is that but man I I can imagine it's
it's a pretty gnarly one to try and
control one thing that is true though is
that his Mastery of zabimaru has
provided some pretty awesome results for
him now zabimaru does have a special
ability called Higa zako or baboon Fang
bite when translated but this is an
ability that renji has rarely used this
is all down to the fact that this
technique is actually damaging to
zabimaru and use of it will leave renji
totally defenseless because of this if
he were to use it in a battle he could
only perform it once biochia also stated
that by using this technique renji will
not be able to reactivate his shikai for
a period of time so the ability what it
does is that renji can use his own
spiritual power to levitate the broken
segments of zabimaru in the air and he
can perform a One-Shot brutal attack
with it
kogakuchi is another anime only
character here he was the former third
seat of the sixth division who later
went on to revolt against the sole
Society his zombog toe is called
muramasa which means Village just when
translated his shikai release command is
whisper and upon its release the zombato
disperses a purple energy that will
cause the zombotto of all the other Soul
Reapers in the area to turn against them
not only does the zampokto disobey the
will of its owner and turn against them
but it will also turn on all of the
other Soul Reaper allies too in doing
this it gives Koga the perfect advantage
to cut his enemies down
Sergeant komamora was the former captain
of the seventh division his zombokto was
called tenken which means Heavenly
retribution when translated his shikai
release command was raw and his zompoc
toe kept the same form as when it was in
its sealed state so his shikai's special
ability was that tenken would create
various Phantom body parts of the
armored giant that would copy the exact
movements of komamora himself these body
parts would have much more enhanced
strength to them and would completely
overwhelm his anime now not as strong as
when the body was complete in his bonkai
form of course but they still packed a
very very impressive punch
simply referred to as love is advised
and the former captain of the seventh
division so his zombokto is called
tengumaru which means long-nosed Goblin
when translated his shikai release
command is crushed down and the
appearance of tengumaru goes from a
katana to that of a very large black
carnabo that looks like a a cactus I
guess you could say I guess you could
say here tengumoru in its shikai form is
also more than twice the height of Love
who stands at six foot two meaning that
his zombok toe in this form is over 12
foot which is just crazy its special
ability is that it can manipulate fire
and has an ability called fire blowing
gavel this is where love will swing his
zonbogto and it will ignite itself in
Flames as he points his zompoc toe down
a fireball is released from its tip that
will explode as soon as it makes contact
with his Target
tessu zaimon is the current captain of
the 7th Division and former Lieutenant
of the seventh division under his
captain komamora so tetsu zaimon is a
strange one being a captain and all
because he is another one where his
abilities are pretty much unknown to us
we don't even know what the name of his
zompoc toe is with that we also do not
know the name of his shika's release
command but we do know what it looks
like so in his shikai form his zompoc
toe extends to that of a large sword
that has another small blade protruding
from it near the tip of the sword other
than that that's about it would love to
know more about this guy though
a towel rindu is the lieutenant of the
seventh division under his captain tetsu
zaimon just as his captain we do not
know the name of rindo's zampokto but we
do know about its shikai abilities so
let's dive into that so his shikai
release command is give birth which he
will write onto his zombok toe using his
finger his zomb October comes like a
whip in segments with each of the
segments resembling different Shinigami
talismans now the ability of his shikai
is that he can use a host of different
attacks by naming an animal using sign
language and that's after he has written
down his shikai's release command on his
zompoc toe so one of the attacks we saw
was called taka which means Hawk when
translated here the different segments
of his zompoc toe turn into Hawks that
will swarm and overwhelm his opponent
their attacks are both ferocious and
Relentless as they rip the flesh from
their target
is the former fourth seat of the seventh
Division and was also the younger
brother of jadanbo his zonpok toe is
called soon zakigurasu which means
splitting Crow when translated so his
shikai release command is spread your
wings to which his zompok toe blade
turns into dozens of flying Beyblades
well I guess they look more like fidget
Spinners I mean are they are they even a
thing by the way anyway its ability is
that jirobo can control each of these
flying blades using his mind now when he
faced off against Ishida he did say that
no one had ever faced his shikai and
lived to tell the tale due to the
awesome speed that his blades possessed
a speed that he said was faster than the
eye could see
that of course didn't end well if you
remember do Bo did have blade Recreation
which was a nice touch to his shikai in
which he could summon more blades if
they were to have been destroyed by
simply sheathing and unsheathing his
sword anime style
Lisa yaromaru is the captain of the
eighth division her zombot 2 is called
haguro tonbo which is translated to mean
Iron dragonfly Hershey Kai's release
command is smash which turns the
appearance of her zompoc toe from a
sword to a long pole with a blade fixed
at his tip similar to that of a monk's
spade and at the other end of the pole
is a large heavy ball the heavy ball at
the end allows her to use her zombac toe
like an ax her sheikhai's special
ability is unknown but we have seen her
use a move called 21st article dragonfly
Landing where Lisa dished out multiple
piercing attacks all at once against her
opponent
tatsufusa in joji is the third seat of
the eighth division under his captain
Lisa his unbox toe is called hosen which
means crumbling mountain when translated
his shikai release command is dance
madly and unfortunately that is all we
know about his shikai really bit of a
let down this one because I feel as if
his shikai's release command sounds
pretty rad and I'd hoped it's in some
pretty sick abilities but unfortunately
not
unfortunately not
kensei muguruma is the captain of the
ninth division he again was a captain
over 100 years ago prior to his Exile
and is also advised his zompoc toe is
called touchakaze which is translated as
meaning earth-severing wind can say
shikai release command is Blast away
it's shikai form turns his zompok toe
into a combat knife now its special
ability comes in the manipulation of
both wind and energy where it slashes
turn into explosions we have seen him
used two abilities using his shikai
which includes air blades where kensei
will release multiple slashes from a
distance that will cut the enemy down
before exploding causing a huge amount
of damage the other ability is called
bomb thrust where kensei charges up
tachikaze with spirit Power till it
takes the form of a glowing ball of
light this he will then fire his enemy
in a devastating and very very powerful
Conor May tozen was the former captain
of the ninth division before he betrayed
the sole Society alongside both sosuke
Eisen and guinea ichimaru his zompokto
is called suzumushi which means Bell
book when translated when it comes to
his shikai tozans is not like a regular
zompoc toe in the fact that it has two
shikai commands both with unique
abilities the first is when he uses the
release command howl his zompoc toe
keeps the same Katana form of its sealed
state but a high-pitched noise occurs
all over a large area all of those that
hear this high-pitched noise will be
knocked unconscious the other shikai
ability is called Cricket second
movement Crimson flying Lotus this
ability turns susumushi into its Benny
hiko form suzumushi begins to vibrate
and as chosen begins to move his sword
in a circular motion a trail will appear
following the sword's movement this
Trail then turns into hundreds of blades
that are then fired straight at his
opponent
Shuhei hisage is the cola tenant of the
ninth division under his captain kensei
mugarumov and of course formerly kaname
tozen his zonpokto is called kazashini
which means death wind when translated
which it sounds really awesome this one
death wind let's go his shikai release
command is reap upon its release his
zompokto takes on the form of two Kusa
regama weapons basically they're like
double-bladed scythes on a spiked pole
that go with his theme both of these
weapons are connected by a chain now
because of the chain aspect Shuhei can
spin these scythes in circles a very
very high speeds making his weapon
appear as if it were like a fan the
chain on his weapon is also extendable
which makes Shuhei a deadly long-ranged
fighter not only can his chain be used
for long range combat but shuhaken also
used the chain to Grapple and wrap
around his opponent he has an ability or
an attack I guess you can say called
kubi Kake or neck hanging when
translated here Shuhei will throw his
weapon at his opponent so that the chain
wraps around their neck here he will
pull on the Chain which will not only
strangle his opponent but it can also be
used to pull his Target closer to him so
that he can strike them with the other
weapon
tosharohi sagaya is the captain of the
10th division his zombok toe is called
hiron Maru which is translated as
meaning ice ring his shikai's release
command is Reign Over the Frosted
Heavens in its release form hironmaru
becomes slightly longer in length and
also gains the addition of a crescent
blade at its Hilt attached by a metal
chain which can also extend and be used
to attack the target here's shikai's
special ability is there allows hit
zagaya to control the elements of water
and ice the slashes he performs are not
only enhanced in power but also create a
form of ice that takes the shape of a
Chinese dragon that will freeze anything
that it touches the difference between
its shikai and bonkai abilities are
pretty small but the abilities of his
shikai are as follows the first is
subjugation of the heavens which is both
his most basic ability but also his
strongest where he can control and
manipulate the water in the atmosphere
around him then he has multi-layer
vacuum ice wall which will create a wall
made of multiple layers of ice because
this is a multi-leveled ice wall it can
even withstand some fire attacks which
of course is the element that he would
be weakest against he can also use this
offensively in a technique called vacuum
ice blade where he will manipulate all
the ice he has gathered and focus it at
the tip of his zompoc toe before firing
it straight at his opponent there is
also another ice wall technique called
woven ice wall where he will erect a
wall of ice by weaving fine threads of
ice together his final shikai ability is
called sixth clothed ice binding array
where he's a Gaia will place five
snowflakes shaped pieces of ice on the
ground that creates a trap that will of
course trap his opponent once they step
on this trap each of the snowflakes send
a line of ice straight at them or then
encase the Target in a giant pillar of
ice
ishin Kurosaki was the former captain of
the 10th division his zambokto is called
engetsu which means scathing moon when
translated ishin shikai release command
is burn the appearance of his zompoc toe
does not change however it is engulfed
in a fire-like spirit energy can use an
energy attack when he is wounded where
he will use his own blood and spit it
onto the sword which will then release
an insane amount of spirit energy that
he will then use to Pummel his opponent
of course the Epic ability a shin can
perform is his own gets Suga tensho
which is incredibly incredibly powerful
he used this against Eisen in the fake
karakura Town not only did it completely
demolish the surrounding buildings but
it also left Eisen with a large gash in
his head earning a compliment a
compliment from Eisen himself Eisen said
that the attack was Splendid and it was
an attack that is Sheen fully understood
rongiku Matsumoto is the lieutenant of
the 10th division under her Captain
toshiro hits a Gaia and is also one of
the baddest bestest girls out there am I
right noise her zambokto is called
heineko which means Ash cat when
translated her shikai release command is
growl when her shikai is activated
rangiku's zampakto turns to Ash this ash
is basically particles that are tiny
blades that wrong geeku can use to cut
her opponent by swinging the hilt of her
sword to control the ashes flow rangiku
can make this ash cover a very large
area to surround single or multiple
targets and with a simple hand gesture
make the ash close in and devastate
those trapped with Ian now the strength
of Ron geeku shikai comes in the amount
of Ash that is covering her Target the
ashes often clumped together so that
more of the tiny blade particles deal
damage to her chosen Target and it can
also be used as a form of Defense as Ron
geeku can use the ash to form a shield
to block any incoming attacks she also
has a move called neku rinbu which means
Cat round dance when translated here
wrong geeku can create and manipu her
Ash to that of a tornado that will wipe
out many enemies at once another move
she has is called house where Ron geeku
can create multiple layers of Ash to
form a wall
kempachi Zaraki is the current captain
of the infamous 11th division and is
also the 11th kempachi to hold the title
his zampokto is called nosarashi which
means weather beaten when translated now
kempachi shikai release command is drink
his zompokto's appearance changes to the
form of a giant ax-like weapon with a
very long grip to it its special ability
in its released form is an insane
power-up in noza Rush's strength and
cutting power its power is enough to
completely destroy a meteorite with just
a single blow kempachi can cook clean
through his opponents with ease even
being able to cut through space itself
is the former Lieutenant of the 11th
division under her Captain kampachi
Zaraki her zonpokto is called sampo
kenju which means three-step sword beast
when translated yachiro hasn't been seen
calling a release command when
activating her shikai but fear not fear
not people we do know what the ability
of her shikai is so upon its release
yachiro shikai summons forth two beasts
that will fight alongside her one of the
creatures is a large skeletal Beast
wearing a black robe with light blue
hair and has a bone that runs vertically
through his head that also wields a
dagger this Beast is referred to as bony
the other Beast which yachiro calls
lumpy is a smaller yellow fluff ball
thats eyes are just visible through said
fur this creature is wielding a
cleaver-like weapon now when yachiro
attacks the two creatures mimic Her
Moves striking with their own weapons
however they attack at different times
the yellows creature attack follows
after yachiros and the larger creatures
after that this is pretty much a triple
attack enhancing the accuracy and
ferocity of yachiro's original attack
meaning that dodging is near impossible
for her opponent
is the lieutenant of the 11th division
under his captain kempachi Zaraki his
zampokto is called hazukimaru which
means winter cherry when translated his
shikai release command is extend when
his shikai activates his zompokto
becomes a spear with a wax wood shaft
and a red horse tail tassel at its
pommel and the blade of course on the
other end his shikai's special ability
is called Break where he separates his
spear into its true form which is that
of a staff with three sections these
three sections can separate and reattach
as and when ikaku wishes because of this
his shikai nearly always catches his
opponent off guard as it makes his
weapon an extremely versatile one that
suits hiku's brutal fighting style these
segments are all connected via a chain
that also extends which lends further
examples of its versatility as it means
that ikaku can fight at both close and
mid-ranged combat
Yumi chica is the third seat of the 11th
division under his captain kempachi's
Iraqi his zombokto is called ruio kujaku
which means Azure peacock when
translated however yumichika has
nicknamed his zompoc toe to Fuji kojaku
which when translated means Wisteria
peacock his shikai release command for
the nicknamed Fuji kujaku is Blossom and
the release command changes when he uses
its true name to tear in frenzy when his
shikai is activated it turns into the
shape of a sickle that has four blades
all in a fan-like shape now its special
ability is that the blades of his shikai
can transform into many vines that look
like peacock feathers The Vines ensnare
his opponents and once trapped The Vines
begin to grow energy buds that start to
fill with the spirit Power of the victim
that is trapped within them once enough
energy has been collected the energy
buds Bloom into flowers and that Spirit
energy is then turned on the one trapped
with Ian which results in Mass damage
and in some cases instant death now the
Petals of the flowers can also be eaten
which will heal wounds or replenish lost
spiritual power the effect of the petal
is equal to the amount of spirit energy
that the petal had consumed
another anime only here is maki ichinose
who was a former member of the 11th
division under his former captain of
course kempachi Zaraki his sambokto is
called nijigasumi which means rainbow
Mist when translated so here's Chicago
release command is Flash and burst Ichi
no says shikai is pretty awesome as he
can Infuse spirit Power into his zompoc
toe and it will create light that he can
use for a number of different techniques
the first is that you can actually make
himself invisible to his opponent by
refracting light all around his body so
that the only thing that his opponent
can see is the area behind him even if
they are looking directly at him this is
perfect for surprising them with very
fast sneak attacks he can also use the
light to Simply blind his enemy this
will buy him time to launch another
attack or he can use it as a way of
making an escape he has an ability
called brilliant void where he can
create a large dimension of light to
affect multiple targets of wants all of
those that are trapped within its
boundary will fall victim to the many
illusions that he can perform using
light which include making it appear as
if there are more than one of him Ichi
knows they can also make the blade of
his zompoc toad change to a blade of
light that is constantly shifting which
he can make the blade itself appear
invisible which he will use to perform
stealth-like attacks this blade though
made of light is still just as hard as
that of a normal blade and just as
lethal a really cool ability with this
blade is that if it is broken Ichi knows
they can pour more Spirit energy into it
which will completely restore the blade
to what it was before it was broken the
the final ability is called psygioko
nijika Sumi where each knows a spirit
Power completely intensifies which
significantly boosts all of his
abilities more so a large twinkling
sphere of light begins to expand around
the area his opponents is in which
causes a lot of pressure to fall on
those who are trapped within it the
sphere begins to compress into a small
beam that will ultimately crush the one
that is trapped within it
mayori kurosuchi is the captain of the
12th division and is also the second
President of the Shinigami Research
Institute he was formerly the third C of
the 12th division under kisuke urahara
so his zompoc toe is called ashishogi
jizo which is translated as the leg
cutting Guardian here's shikai's release
command is rip and the form of his
zompoc toe changes to that of a golden
Trident with curved blades the god of
the zompoc toe is shaped like a baby's
head with its hands in prayer very very
creepy looking so mayuri's shikai's
special ability is that of a Venom when
his opponent is stabbed by ashishoki
jizo the signals from the brain that
control movement are severed leaving
them paralyzed the only thing not
affected by the Venom is the nerve
endings and pain receptors meaning that
his opponent will still be able to feel
all the pain the paralyzed lemon Jaws he
also has a shikai ability called leg
cutting jizo Terror magnitude 4. where
mayori sticks his finger in one eye of
the baby's head on his zompoc toe
causing a dark fluid to come out of the
baby's mouth anyone who does not share
the same blood as mayori who will then
hear this sound will be completely
paralyzed for four seconds short amount
of time but in battle that's a long time
ARA was the former captain of the 12th
Division and also the founder and first
president of the Shinigami research and
development Institute his zombogto is
called benihime which is translated as
Crimson princess his shikai's release
command is awaken and the blade takes
the form of a medium-sized sword that
has a decorative Hilt and a crimson
tassel hanging from it so key Sky's
shikai's ability is a vary of techniques
that manipulate a crimson energy and
through verbal commands from kisuke
benehime will execute said technique the
first is sing Crimson princess scream
which are blasts of ferocious and
destructive Crimson energy that are
fired in the shape of an ark these
blasts are strong enough to take on and
a Sparta Class A rancor's Cerro
bloodmess Shield is where a
hexagon-shaped crimson barrier forms a
defensive perimeter blocking incoming
attacks raise a crimson princess is a
technique very similar to sing Crimson
princess scream where it again fires an
arc of crimson energy straight towards
its Target cutting them with ease
spurning Crimson princess is a technique
that will cancel out an enemy's attack
upon contact all kisuke has to do is
analyze the opponent's technique which
is basically the spiritual energy
composition and the muscle movements
once that is done a circle of crimson
energy is drawn that will cancel out
said attack
Crimson princess of binding is a blood
red net made of condensed energy being
thrown over the target from the tip of
benihime's Blade using a slashing motion
the final ability is called fire playing
Crimson princess beaded MASH which is
performed after using the previous blood
red net technique kisuke will stab the
net with the tip of benihime's Blade
that will create Balls of Fire all over
the outside of the net that will then
explode like mines devastating
completely devastating the one trapped
within the net
hiori saragaki is the former Lieutenant
of the 12th division under her Captain
kisuke urahara her zonpokto is called
kubikiki Orochi which means head slicing
serpent when translated her shikai
release command is chop cleanly and upon
its activation hyori zompoc toe becomes
a large Cleaver that looks more like a
saw than it does a sword now
unfortunately we do not know what the
ability of our shikai is but looking at
the appearance of her zompoc toe as well
as its shikai's release command I'm sure
it would have been utterly utterly
brutal
okay yushima is an anime only character
and a member of the 12th division his
zompoc toe is called Sumi sukigasa which
means ink moon halo when translated now
we do not know what his shikai's release
call is but we do know a couple of
details about it so for one we know
about its appearance change as his
zompoc toe takes on the form of a
double-headed Valk that has red markings
on it we also know that its special
ability is Portal generation where
yushima can create portals to the dungai
by twirling his thumbpock toe
rookie akushki is the current captain of
the 13th division where she formally
served as a lieutenant under juiciro
ukitake her zonpokto is called sood no
shirayuki which means sleeves of white
snow when translated Hershey Kai release
command is dance now so no shirayuki is
described as the most beautiful zompoc
toe in all of the Soul society and when
it's in its sheikhai form the blade
still looks like a normal Katana but a
very very elegant one it also has a very
long white ribbon from the hilt that
forms a perfect circle when Rukia holds
the blade upside down so so no shirayuki
is an ice type zompoc toe and its shikai
form has multiple techniques it can
perform that are all labeled as dances
the zompokto's standard shikai ability
is that it freezes it can freeze targets
from a distance or create Paths of eyes
in mid-air interestingly it's not the
Hershey Kai freezes objects from the
blade but it actually drops the
temperature of what it touches to below
freezer
basically anything rookia touches will
be affected her sambok toe only extends
her reach the abilities or dances
available to her sheikai form are as
follows so no my tsukishiro or first
dance Moon white is a technique where
Rukia holds the glowing blade upside
down making a slashing motion when the
enemy is in position at that moment she
draws a circle with the tip of her
zombog toe anything within that circle
is Frozen not only the ground but the
air too everything within that circle's
perimeter is frozen into a pillar of
light shortly after that the pillar as
well as the target shatters completely
to note if the target is not trapped
within the pillar said pillar will not
shatter tsugi nomai hakurun or next
dance white Ripple is a circle of ice
similar to the previous ability that
will form where Rukia stabs the ground
she will stab the ground four times in a
semi-circle and ice particles come up
from those punctures rookia then takes
up a stance and these particles flow to
the tip of a zombac toe that she will
then release in a very powerful cold
blast of air freezing everything that it
comes into contact with sadomai
shirafune or third dance white sword is
an ability where Rukia gathers all of
the moisture in the air to the tip of
their zompoc toe forming a blade of
complete ice this not only increases the
reach of her blade but also freezes
everything that makes contact with the
blade
or tree white is a direction of ice that
forms a trail towards her Target when
she strikes the ground that will
continue to freeze until that Target is
turned to ice
rookia also has something called ice
rope connection where she can create an
ice extension that will connect her hand
to the hilt of her zompoc toe if she is
out of its reach allowing her to use her
sheikhai abilities at a distance
is the former captain of the 13th
Division and the final captain on our
list his zompoc toe is called Tokyo no
kotawari which is translated as law of
the twin his shikai release command is
all waves rise and become my shield
lightning strike now and become my blade
and once ishikai has released his single
Katana becomes two blades that he dual
wields as the two blades separate a
large red rope with five silver charms
appear that attaches to the hilts of
both swords now his shikai's special
ability is being able to absorb his
opponent's energy through the left sword
that will then travel through the red
rope and its five silver charms that
will increase the Energy's attack speed
and power reaching the right sword here
ukitake will fire it straight back at
his opponent with much more devastating
Force this process happens so fast that
it is pretty much unable to dodge
Cayenne Shiba is the former Lieutenant
of the 13th division under his captain
juiciro ukitake his zombokto is called
nejibana which means Twisted flower when
translated his shikai release command is
raged through the sea and heavens and
when his shikai is activated his sonbok
toe takes on the new form of a trident
and spear water will flow from both the
Trident and spear end of his zompoc toe
now his shikai's special ability is in
the manipulation of water being hit by
the water that his zompokto creates is
described as being hit by the crushing
waves of the sea themselves water
constantly flows from his zompoc toe to
which he can surround the entire area in
water or he can fire waves of water in
the form of slashes by using his zonpok
toe
xenosuki is the sole Reaper who replaced
Rukia kuchki as the guardian of the
areas around karakura town he is also a
member of the 13th division his zombokto
is called tsuchi namsu which means Earth
catfish when translated his shikai
release command is good morning which is
pretty amusing in itself right anyway
his zombogto changes to the form of a
Wind and Fire wheel his shikai's special
ability is that it can cause earthquakes
when he strikes the ground with his
zompoc toe a red energy causes the Earth
itself to shake to which he can even
send Rubble straight at his opponent not
only that but he can forms said Rubble
into sharp spikes that will impale his
enemies we also saw zanusuke manipulate
the Earth to form a cage in which he was
able to trap and ensnare his Target
is the leader of the zero division his
zonpok toe is called ichimanji which
means one written character when
translated his shikai release command is
paint it black upon activation his brush
like zompoc toe turns into a glaive
where its top portion has a short blade
its special ability is that the blade
will release an ink when it is swung by
each Bay that whatever said in covers
loses its name and in losing their name
that Target also loses their powers
interestingly its power is black itself
meaning that the color black from all
things be them living or dead becomes
his own power it must be said that this
power can be stolen from him however it
cannot be used against him because the
power of black is commanded by ichibe
alone he also has another move called
slaughterous Mausoleum of halted
reincarnation that sounds absolutely
incredible right so here each mace
summons a huge amount of black from all
of his surrounding area that he then
fills into a cup ichibe then drinks from
said cup and chants that an incantation
that summons a huge Mausoleum this
Mausoleum takes away all the darkness in
his opponent which includes their Flesh
Blood and Bones until nothing absolutely
nothing is left of them and that person
also to make it worse will never be able
to reincarnate
is a member of the royal guard and the
first officer of the zero division his
zonpok toe is called Kim Pika which
means gilded Splendor when translated
his shikai release command is Heavenly
Flash and when his shikai is released
the blade of his zompoc toe glows
however that is unfortunately all we
know about his shikai which is a real
shame as his powers are sure to be super
impressive
anime only rusaburo and kogawa commonly
referred to as enriou is one of
roricio's bodyguards his zonpokto is
called daichimaru which means the land
when translated his shikai release
command is rock and when his shikai is
activated his zonpok toe turns into a
pair of large black fists these two
fists are also connected by a chain that
goes from you know one fist to enrius
and then through to the other enriusikai
is a defensive one and its special
ability is that he can create a trail of
rocks when he punches the ground these
rocks go in the direction of his
opponent and when it reaches them a pair
of large white hands emerge from the
ground that ensnare the target this can
be used to either trap an enemy or to
protect the one trapped within from
attacks as the hands are very very
durable
Final sheikhai on the list and it's an
anime only again ryuse kenzaki commonly
referred to as kenrio is one of
ririchio's bodyguards his zombogto is
called Benny shidare which means Crimson
weeping bow when translated his shikai
release command is blue madly now when
his shikai is activated his zompoc
becomes a long black sword with five
flowers on the blade this thing
certainly looks very underwhelming but
it does have a pretty cool ability so
its ability is that the flowers begin to
release a pollen that will cause more
flowers to appear but this time on his
opponent's weapon this then renders it
useless to them if the pollen were to be
blown away that person's weapon would be
useful to them again this pollen can
also be used as a diversion tactic when
Ken Ryu blows it into his enemy's face
this temporarily blinds them giving
kenry utan to escape or land a strike of
his own he also has a second ability in
which he can scatter his flower was to
send a large amount of energy needles to
rain down upon his opponent
and that is it every sheikhai from
Bleach explained there was certainly a
lot to cover in this video and I really
do hope that I did manage to get them
all if I did miss one let us know in the
comment section below also let us know
which of the shikai was your favorite
and which one do you think is the most
powerful of them all of course if you
enjoyed this video and you'd like to see
more bleach videos on the channel make
sure to let us know by Smashing that
like button if you haven't make this the
video you subscribe and hit the
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
anime abroad videos remember you can
also follow us on Twitter and Instagram
at anime uproar thanks again and we
can't wait to see you in the next one
till next time my friends take care
peace